[Musique]
et
quant à pierre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
danse
là
[Musique]
jed
plushenko qui est avec nous magnifique
alors ça vient d'arriver ça ça va
arriver à paris je peux vous dire ça
arrive sûrement pas à paris demain
franchement je les ai essayé la sont
magnifiques
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa part franchement il est sympa une
chaîne merci d'avoir été avec nous
franchement on te souhaite beaucoup de
chance pour la trottinette on rappelle
ces voix là c'est vraiment en plus les
prix sont hyper raisonnable et je le
répète c'est écologique et la regarder
le design de la trottinette téléphone